[Music]
then overreacting news all I overreact
submitted by Shakira Shakira Shakira
Shakira the white club sake - a kid did
- dude is like a man got the symbol for
neutered tattooed on his arm after
assuming the ink on his dog was a sign
of abuse wait what
a man got the symbol for neutered
tattooed oh there should be a comma and
man got the symbol for a neutered
tattooed on his arm after assuming the
ink on his dog was a sign of abuse well
you mean that little Krammer new ink on
an on the on the weiner area they leave
yeah well that's not ink is it I thought
that was this the stitching that stains
the skin when it heals I don't I don't
know
apparently it's a tattoo mm-hmm so this
man his name is Chris he's from Texas he
posted this up so it's the foot of his
dog and his arm would you like to read
kissy for those of you who know bear
know that he has a tattoo given to him
from the some previous owners it sickens
me to know that people actually tattooed
their pets so tonight I got his tattoo
wait this was so stupid he thinks that
the dog was abused and then like they
tend though he got it so that's the
symbol on his arm is exactly what's on
the dog it seems like it I can't I can't
make it just think a lot of blue mm-hmm
that stands for neutered dog well I mean
I thought that it was a stitching that
when the dog heals it kind of like heals
with the skin and it stains it blue
I didn't I didn't know that it was a
tattoo I don't think any stitching would
stain oh I don't know I just remember
when I got Brown neutered his the stitch
that they use you could kind of see that
it looked like there was something
underneath his skin yeah it was like it
did not my color maybe that was yeah but
apparently this dog had that symbol
tattooed and so I'm gonna show you guys
a small clip of him talking so he claims
that before he got it tattooed he
discovered that it was the symbol for
neutered shirt he knew he claimed that
he knew I knew what it was I still think
it's wrong
pretty much it's what do you think yeah
no I don't think he did it right like
cuz he didn't get in the same spot oh
yeah it's got to be a leg that's being
the exact same spot if you want to do it
right if he's a picture of him covering
his balls then it's like this on the
hood yeah oh it's supposed to be here
yeah yeah yeah so get another one yeah
to make it right
yeah cuz that's it that symbol it's the
male symbol like cross that with the
zero with the O so that literally means
that his balls are gone they're crossed
out so he neutered now pretty much at so
every birthing I just thought it was
like a dot o and I've done a lot of
negative remarks I read about people
saying you had no idea what you were
doing you you did it and then you
realize what a midnight I was trying to
say you're gonna cover it up but he
doesn't want to cover it up Christa's he
knew he'd get backlash for being before
he did it but didn't care his life was
ooh yawns what see this tattooed on my
yeah
[Music]
we have a piece of you know it's like my
version of a lumpy huh
yeah I couldn't make out that last part
was like his version of a lucky rabbit's
foot maybe they do tattoo in Texas
because um are our dogs like neutered
the sign doesn't look like that it's
just a blue ink so that's what it looks
like on a dog it's a circle with a yeah
all right I can't see the dog doggy you
can't is it is it blurry or yeah you
can't make it out it's kind of hard to
see what what the dog has isn't does
meatloaf have the blue blue dot no not
that I've seen it might be buried under
his fur yeah he's kind of free yeah you
can't really make it out not sure you
got him from the pound right yeah
because if he was not neutered
previously like at the pound when they
neuter they would do that yeah so if
they pick up dogs on the street they
could kind of check wiener okay cuz I
think some dogs yeah like you you don't
know that I don't know their balls all
shriveled up and stuff and you think
they're neutered already oh yeah yeah I
admire what this guy is trying to do but
then I just feel like what he was doing
is so weird like let's say his dog is
known to hump other dogs is he gonna get
like a rainbow flag tattooed on his
forearm to have to do it don't you
celebrate homosexuality oh you mean like
hump other guy dog yeah like it's just
so like I feel like if you want to do a
direct stance then maybe don't you cut
your own balls off instead of doing the
symbolism of what that's supposed to be
yeah cuz that you're saying that this is
a chance for him to speak out against
mutilating animals
wait so Z against the neutering or is he
against the tattooing the tattooing
initially but then based on that comment
being too but that's no but that's a
problem in itself these dogs multiply
ei officially recommends neutering all
the pets because it prevents testicular
cancer prostate problems and pet
homelessness so speaking a nooner they
stopped they made it illegal now for pet
stores to have purebred Dougie's that
are from puppy mills and all that in
California yeah we talked about that so
that's that's a good thing because I
think man there's so many dogs being put
to sleep every week in every single
shelter I think they only keep them for
like four or five days until they got a
go bye-bye is that four or five days
because of how packed they are there
wasn't as many dogs there then the 4-5
days could potentially be months maybe
even you know how packed it is but
there's also the price to feed them I
mean that's true so like a Tyson right
he's leave my my dad's house Tyson got
loose somehow they knew exactly where he
lived and they took them and then they
left a note on my house to say if I
don't pick it up pick him up in seven
days then he's gonna be put to sleep and
I'm like but you it's not a stray dog
you know where this dog lives to the
point where you can put the housing I
mean that know exactly on the right
house but that's just how bad it is
cuz you know what'll suck - is that like
let's say you're out of town and then
they leave it there yeah and then you
come back and it's already been like two
weeks and [ __ ] you're like yeah but like
I like animals so go to the pound rescue
a dog yes and now this guy he's using
all the backlash and attention to direct
it towards a GoFundMe page I he created
do to remove his tattoo that would be
for a local no kill shelter that's cool
that's cool yeah so so far he's raised
three hundred and fifty dollars out of
the $3,000 goal so what happens to the
doggies and no-kill shelters that no one
wants you go to foster homes oh but what
if no one wants him at all oh I don't
know you just stay at the shelter until
they die I think so
than they do imagining that dog get a
lot of foster people that want to foster
they just pass him around
yeah I'm finding a pattern with these
Inside Edition stories they're very like
run arnie cuz it starts off with he
doesn't like mutilation because of the
tattoos and the tattoo is that of
neutering and now he doesn't like
neutering so he got a tattoo and now
he's gonna donate the money to a no-kill
shelter but it started off with he
didn't like tattoos on dogs
you know what Inside Edition is it's the
I don't know what's going on see the
logic of how how it connects it's just
like now I knit sweaters and afternoons
next on what's the point
[Laughter]
talking and people submit like people
that are watching they submit Inside
Edition story so they like the stories
that they had but I just I wish I
understood what was going on I think
it's just brainless like it's not like
real news it's just like it's supposed
to go in one ear out the other while
you're waiting for dinner to get done
it's more like us it's really awesome
like so and so this happened to
so-and-so and now we're talking about it
it's it's I feel like it's my social
commentary on the fact that humans
cannot for the life of them admit that
they are wrong like we have human ego is
like animals it's funny that's about
dogs - it's like animals don't have egos
but humans do and this is like prime
example of a human not being it able to
admit that he's wrong because after all
the backlash you could have been that
was stupid yeah but instead he's like
I'm gonna use this to channel all this
negative energy and to this go fund me
page has nothing to do with why I was
holding even started yeah yeah that's
why people are like you're just kind of
save face cuz I mean if he made sense
like if he was against neutering and he
did that at least he has a point
yeah or if he's even if it's stupid at
least he has a point
I don't get the point my switch stances
he just yeah it's like cool you
something because you thought it had
meeting meaning for your dog cool you
know like you're against tattooing dogs
well I don't get the point he's like
going from one thing to another and it's
either I'm just [ __ ] stupid and I
don't get the point at all because I'm
not gonna be one of those people that
are like mmm yes yes yes I understand
like I can't I can't pretend that I
don't [ __ ] understand I don't
understand can someone explain it to me
cuz I just feel like I watched someone
that keeps switching in and like they're
not making a clear point yeah
Inside Edition what the [ __ ] is the
point yeah did anyone donate to that
GoFundMe page I got 300 bucks $350 how
much was he asking for 3,000 I'll donate
just to ask him what's the point
do I need to know this is two stories
that we did on Inside Edition and it
chipped away a piece of my soul because
I'm now obsessed I'm now obsessing over
what the point is like is there as what
is the reason there has to be something
good chunk of the stories we talk about
here and never have a point they do
though all right like all right it's
either
there's no point or like sure there's a
point but why the [ __ ] are we talking
about it no but most stories though they
state they go full circle or they
satisfy like the reason right you know
what this is like it's it's kind of like
this okay October October 31st children
are gonna go trick-or-treating and on
Thanksgiving we're gonna eat turkey
there's the holiday yeah actually my
point made more [ __ ] point does it
let me [ __ ] well you're the one to prove
me a news article I know it cuz it
sounded really funny when I saw the
title uh and then when we see the story
I'm like I need to know what happens
next
are they the moral of the story is if
you [ __ ] up just admit that you [ __ ] up
and it's like it's more endearing than
going the Hobbes ah no
I think the moral of the story is if you
[ __ ] up to start a GoFundMe page I mean
I guess it ended on a positive note like
he [ __ ] up saving face at least the
money's gonna go towards a good cause
yeah I feel like starting a GoFundMe is
like by begging for money on the streets
it's exactly what it is now on the
streets of the debit debit debit unless
we do a movie that's different in the
triple bond if we do a movie yeah it
says that's for art what's up guys how
do we do did you like it did you hate it
well guess what there's only a like
button and if you like that that's the
way to communicate that to us so make
sure to hit that like button and for
more episodes click right above me